49 seconds of three logos I am so
fucking sick of fucking logos man this
used to mean something
goddamn Sam take a movie off you don't
have to appear in everything News
article tells us that people have long
known about peculiars but this is
definitely not the case during the rest
of the movie so unless this is a
clipping from The Daily Prophet it's
some bull did they just peculiar eyes
Santa Claus I know he's a real person
but doesn't sound like ransom riggs it's
the name of a character Mel Gibson would
put in his next movie do you ever feel
like nothing you do matters all the time
given Hollywood's remakes equal machine
thanks for asking also peculiar Asian
it's not safe
stay away well it's also not safe to
have an extremely visible annotated map
of all the secret loop entrances but I
guess we'll get to that later
Shelley is largely unconcerned with a
sudden apparition that appeared in the
middle of the goddamn road grandpa oh no
grandpa's been ransacked and suddenly
this movie is way more national treasure
than it wants to be someone broke in
I've got a 38 in my car you wait there
even in the age of cellphones movie
characters will go to great lengths to
not immediately call the police at a
crime scene
trevor how many times have i told you
kid sees a bloody flashlight and grabs
it blood fence that only Godzilla could
have wrecked this badly let's examine
this further
grandpa has either a bloody carving fork
or a bloody tuning fork in his hand and
the fact that I don't care says a lot
about this mystery and I'm gonna have to
get away from here how is he still alive
enough to give the cryptic instructions
everyone else that this happens too in
this movie is dedicated
but the bird will explain everything oh
okay gotcha that's actually what I
expected you to say I was expecting that
I thought I could protect Asa
Butterfield isn't acting here he's
genuinely concerned his co-star has had
a stroke it's the super authentic
concerned what's going on right now face
I should have told you years ago father
figure of character with all the
important information dies before
getting it all out cliche also this
movie is giving me way more John Carter
flashbacks than I think a tribute maybe
I just have John Carter PTSD or
something considering this was only a
month ago I think you're doing
exceptionally well holy Sh they got him
right into counseling after the death of
a loved one even if the doctor is
actually an evil Hollow in disguise
that's actually pretty fantastic so I'll
remove one sin date dna-tested the floor
Janet had animal DNA so that's case
closed he sounds like an extraordinary
gentleman maybe he was but why the what
Samuel oh Jenny say this after the
coroner DNA comment which had nothing to
do with this character and everything to
do with his murder
we're very close footage indicates that
yes they were close as grandpa regaled
grandson with tales of treasure and wait
a minute I'm getting national treasure
vibes here again that's where I hate
from the monsters
telling a kid this age stories like this
regardless of truth this is stuff kids
this age need stories about fairies and
talking animals and Jesus not monsters
in another dimension everything's
already been discovery buddy you dad the
headmistress miss Peregrine's it was a
home for special children that's special
children and not gifted youngsters
because we don't wanna get our Fox
properties confused this is the exact
opposite of an orgy of evidence that
this is a boy's room we have a couple of
dinosaur figures near the lamp base a
few personal drawings a random panda and
a detailed world map this kid either
hates sports or was literally Niles
crane or both this is the cleanest
fucking elementary school classroom I've
ever seen they're telling me not one of
these kids has moved their composition
books from the upper left
corner of their desk even accidentally
it's fun
and given it's your birthday I'm
guessing grandpa's gift is about to kick
start the plot at least dive I hope it
does there's just one hotel
how do you they're rolling number a
cliched ahead have a drink why don't you
I like how this movie's hero basically
takes a tug boat to the island place of
script conflict here's a place of
business named the priests whole world
war whatever wall pictures paint a
picture of the what the fucking hell is
that horrifying laps care I was just
wondering if any of you guys might be
interested and taken my son here to the
other side of the island I get he's got
his shoes but what kind of father
travels to an island with his son then
dumps him off on the first group of
Street locals he comes across well the
sickest office in Wales what happens
when UK teens watch eight-mile for the
first time
I think I'll kind of bog base for
eternity prank is this hahaha you're new
and you don't know this territory so
we'll make a step in a sinkhole of oil
hahaha god we're hilarious right okay
this part of the story takes place in
the present day so why the didn't Jake
Google Maps this place or at least call
someone in the area before making the
goddamn trip from Florida to Wales even
if this islands primitive they've got
ping phones you need to talk about all
this with someone funny like you we
should call dr. Colin oh so not you this
clock reminds me that it's almost 25
minutes into this movie about peculiar
children and all I can think about is
how boring it is a giant motherfucking
bomb fell through the roof of this room
but the glassware is still intact
must have been very selective about its
destructive abilities hilariously this
stumble apparently knocks him out cold
and roger goodell immediately issued a
statement denying football had anything
to do with it look if I woke up in the
arms of a female toddler carrying me I'd
flip the fuck out so kudos to this kid
for keeping his call also these two face
covered goddamn you'd be creepy enough
without that drawn on eyebrows goddamn
you creepy creepos Millard's supposed to
be invisible
not ethereal so why doesn't this mist
reveal the shape of his face
activating the portal sounds like the
first track on a spooky sounds for
Halloween CD like many before him Jake
runs away from scary adventure back to
the creepy loving arms of the priest
toll each American movie has time for
this of course it's a two-hour long
movie so it has time for virtually
anything Jesus he's invisible not
Quicksilver how's Millard getting to all
this dinner we're so quickly did olive
literally just torched the pub there's
still like 40 people in there holy these
peculiar children are secretly nihilists
it is 1943 September the 3rd 1943 all
day every day it's all loop so this is a
magic infused World War 2 Groundhog Day
cuz that's an awesome idea but you still
made this movie somehow right Tom tie
between the stylized hair the pale
complexion and the exaggerated accent in
a Tim Burton movie it's clear Ava green
has become the female Johnny Depp miss
peregrine's home for second hand smoke
inhalation know a few things I can't
explain for example what happened to Tim
Burton's career after Ed Wood some
people at peculiar it's a recessive gene
carried down through families since that
territory's never been covered before
I'm the type of peculiar called an in
brain an in brains main skill is the
manipulation of time we choose a safe
place a safe day and create agent this
is the exact day their house is bombed
though I know she can stop it before it
happens but there must be thousands of
other days that are safer right it is
pretty nice that they can get by with
just one giant carrot instead of a bunch
of smaller ones but peeling that
motherfucker is gonna be a bitch this
movie's home for peculiar children
prominently features an apple tree
immediately making me suspect to the
entire enterprise
damn he was an asshole he unleashes the
same bee power for a pickup soccer game
that he later uses in a life-or-death
situation we'll discuss this later it
wasn't their fault this movie's laziness
Emma literally told miss Peregrine's
what happened at the pub as soon as they
return then miss Peregrine's told Jake
she expected some kerfuffle before they
headed back but now suddenly Emma's in
trouble jake takes the blame so we have
some manufactured warmth between the two
of them would you mind sign that rope
around my waist I'm sorry all I heard
was my waist you want me to do what now
also less do you think I'm being pervy
for bringing this up just look at how
this movie chose to shoot this scene
also the only way Jake would need to get
this close to Emma to tie this rope as
if he were training to be the next
Christian Grey mister hold on tight I
know they're all getting along well but
Emma is putting a massive amount of
trust into it dude she just met one slip
of the rope and she's fucked what reason
would Emma have to put the squirrel back
in the tree except to show off her
powers it's a fuckin squirrel it wants
to climb back up in the tree that's what
they do also he's totally looking up
address right now as a matter of
function even if he's not turned on he
basically has to look up her dress to
bring her down safely was he like you he
was like you Jake will continue to
assume Jake has abilities without
specifically acknowledging the abilities
it wouldn't be a Tim Burton movie if we
didn't have a nightmarish steampunk
lobster baby doll do you want to see the
fun part the first rule about dom-based
Fight Club is you don't talk about doll
based Fight Club one doll has a lobster
hand but the other has a full-on goddamn
kitchen knife this is an unfair fight
how does this not happen at every meal
then god damn it this movie just yearns
to bust it's not on FX whenever it can
look cool you know this is downright
unnatural and wrong and this girl should
be a foster home for demons you should
all get ready for movie time when I own
suppose dinner's lasted less than 350
minutes but forget let's move on to the
next scene Dame Judi Dench is all mi had
a dream and thus the film budget was
increased by however much Judi Dench
demanded which wasn't a lot and then
just continued as normal
this reinforces the point that this was
a stupid day to pick for the immigrant
I'm gobbledygook and was selected only
to synthesize some tension why would the
record play forward when time is still
going backward if you're gonna do
something like this movie can't do it
right what was that it was my phone
movie is almost an hour in and the only
conflict we've had it was way back when
the limey got his eyes ripped out it's
amazing that a story about kids with
magical abilities is so goddamn dull you
might even show them this photograph and
I'll still be here I should have called
this movie miss Spiderwick school for
unfortunate wimpy Potter's where are you
going downstairs for a drink and I will
need my heavy parka for that no wait
they've had time to get all the way from
the school to the hotel be accosted by
the farmer get settled into the room
make a phone call to the therapist and
have an argument if everything ages
after a few minutes when it's out of the
loop like Emma said earlier this flower
should be literally fucking dust right
now if I recall Miss Avocet has a loop
there please warn her and suggest that
she make a new one right away once again
if they can build new loops whenever
they want why wouldn't they do it more
often for a safety and variety I hate
these loops ha ha these white I have
motherfuckers are right in the middle of
a crowd and they have their picture
taken but no one notices it all mom
listen meet a fellow Birds Botha look I
like birds as much as the next guy
probably more this movie is supposed to
be about peculiar children I can't
believe I'm actually looking forward to
seeing this dude eventually become
samuel l.jackson generic movie villain
what's the point
dad perfectly sums up the first half of
this movie she knot it in brains always
female then how do they procreate I
found him in the woods with his eyes
missing and I'm just telling you this
right now even though it's really the
first thing I should have said upon
meeting you I asked you not to ask
questions
god damn someone tell him what the fuck
is going on we're over an hour into the
fucking movie this boating excursion
brings up yet another question about how
far they can go from the home presumably
miss Peregrine's clock applies to the
kids themselves not the island so
couldn't they just wander off anywhere
then come back before the clock resets
my point is these kids are immortal but
they do the same damn thing every day
oh yeah I also have this awesome ability
that has nothing to do with my floaty
thing but I won't tell you about it
until you've risked your life trying to
save me
and the shoes are barely heavy enough to
offset her Flo tattooed on land so
should not be able to weight her down
this much in deep water apparently these
people just sat here patiently at their
dinner table while they waited to die as
the ship sank even though it reportedly
took 18 hours to sink of course this
girl is wearing all white after the
water logging because what good is a
middling movie about magic aimed at
preteens without a little wet t-shirt
action movie briefly speaks to the
audience that's collectively fighting
off a coma
I'm just Mane King character and a movie
about special people says this bull less
than half the movie left to go Jake only
a peculiar an entertainment movie
jargons you into submission miss
Peregrine's kills this hollow everyday
in 1943 the loop continues but so does
regular time and the hollow definitely
dies on this debt so you mean in the
next 73 years neither Baron or the other
evil peculiars have realized this
asshole was missing and came to
investigate the coals amon aghast
because we're terrible at coming up with
names for things I will explain
everything Jake it'll occur around
halfway through the movies fourth hour
he kidnapped Anna Marie not knowing
caring whether she would survive the
experiment scientist Baron forgets how
to science in this experiment and
subjects all these assholes to the
imporant transfer instead of just one at
a time Jesus Christ I've seen better
effects in Raiders of the Lost Ark and
that was in 1981 the rest of the
Moustakas Hallows he needs no more eyes
himself okay there were only 11 people
that were turned into hollows and at
least five of them are pretty much human
now one is dead because miss Peregrine's
keeps killing it in 1943 so there are
only five left that need to be converted
this brings up the question shouldn't
they have more carefully dispensed that
eyeball orgy they had or shouldn't they
found enough in the ensuing years to
help out the few that we're left miss
Avocet punches another hole in the
hollow lure if her kids were consumed
then there should be plenty of eyeballs
to convert the rest of them back to
human form this deed was blindness so
whichever hollow got to him got some
bulk Bibles movie takes Goonies ending
and anza what if there was still to
figure out ending onto it leading to
this father-son beach chase dr. Dalton
times when it suits me and I guess we'll
add shape-shifting powers to Berens bag
of tricks which no one else can do
because why the fuck even after
crazy-eyed samuel l.jackson shows up
with a goddamn knife for a hand movie
continues to be fucking mind-numbing
here's invisible boy closing some
shutters continuing to be utterly wasted
by this movie jake has a clean shot here
but realizes there's another thirty
minutes left in this fucking thing and
refuses to mercifully shorten the
runtime
Emma can float in control air but will
be dangerously sliding down a wet roof
in the scene listen I don't even care if
somehow I'm making a sunken ship
seaworthy is something that Emma can do
I just wish there would have been some
indication that our powers were this
impressive ship that still has a massive
hole in it is able to float effortlessly
and the waterlogged coal is able to burn
his fuel that's science kids there's a
loop here in blackboard with Miss Avocet
gone one two loop closed why hasn't it
already
miss avocets been away from it at least
a day goddamn now the movie is making me
actively cognitively engaged with why I
hate it if we kill baron he'll be gone
but time will carry on he won't go to
Florida Abe won't die he's probably not
considering if Baron dies there's a
massive chain of events that will be
affected and Jake may never even be
conceived pretty sure he's not thinking
forth dimensionally luckily for the
secrecy of the peculiars no one is
around to see this previously sunken
ship docking this can't be it can be
anyway only balls miss Emerson sucked it
in Breen not only is the loop entrance
in plain sight but the loop itself is at
a goddamn crowded amusement park that
just opened was she trying to get caught
in cocksucking balls the fact that these
skeletons were perfectly placed in the
dining room is the only way Enochs
ability could be used and it bullsh some
ass muggles stand around looking at the
enormous probably dangerous creatures
instead of getting the fuck out of the
way these hollows were previously shown
to be the most dangerous things in the
world but are now reduced to clunky set
pieces waving their arms around in the
final fight because we need to see more
of this remaster clip from jason and the
argonauts
Olive is able to set huge fires were
there touch but only lightly ignites
Barron's coat
rather than immediately assault you with
this bowling pin hang on while I find a
random viable heart and make a minion
out of this animatronic elephant that
will become slowly sentient Jesus I
think samuel l.jackson now charges by
the exclamation let me say for what
seems like the 1450 second time since I
started watching this final act why
didn't they do that at the beginning of
this fight ten extra sins for all the
times they should have done something
sooner rather than shooting another air
load at Barron Emmet runs away so we can
have a final unnecessary conflict sudden
hatchet hand is sudden and here we are
with only our wits and our will to
sustain us when you signed up for this
movie did you really think the finale
would be about literal birds being led
out of their cages where the did the
police go they were just investigating
on the mayhem a few minutes ago I know
it feels like the last scene took
forever but it wasn't that long these
assholes are seriously derelict in their
duties wait Jake was in England with a
loop closed if his grandpa didn't die
and Baron dr. Golan didn't exist there
would be no reason for his trip overseas
somehow the did he get all the way back
to Florida okay did we establish whether
or not Abe had a relationship with Emma
but strongly implied he did so not only
should it be weird that Jake's hooking
up with his grandpa Seth's girlfriend
should be extra weird for Emma to use
Jake as their sloppy seconds
tell me your sins my son can you tell me
a story when I was in prison second time
no third stretch yep there was this
screw what really had it in for me and
that geezer was top of my list I could
have gone up behind him and snapped his
fucking neck by lefty or baby squirrel
and we'd have to send away for some
special really tiny instruments
[Music]
if you can dodge the wrench you can
dodge a ball play with this daddy
it is 1943 September the 3rd 1943 all
day every day
I wake up every day right here